Isaiah Garza is our Drew-Gooder ambassador,
and he is coming to us live, from the West Coast.
Isaiah, you have made kindness go viral on social media
and it is your mission to share stories like this.
I must say, nobody does it quite like you.
And we're about to surprise some very special Drew-Gooders.
Are you excited?
I'm super, super excited right now, guys.
Okay, so, I would love for you to see this backstory.
Take a look.
The first time I met Teldrick, he was in third grade.
He was just moving from another school
into the school that I work at.
I've never had that experience before,
where you just meet someone and you kind of know,
like, there's something that's different
or special about them.
So I was gonna go on a solo backpacking trip to the summer
and it was a couple of days before I was leaving.
And his mom called and she was pretty upset,
and she said, "Teldrick was airlifted down
to Children's Hospital last night,
and he's not expected to make it."
I went down to the hospital.
He was in the PICU, at Children's Hospital,
hooked up to hundreds of machines.
It was insane. I've never seen anything like it in my life.
He woke up probably five days, where he was out of the coma.
He was awake and he was starting to move,
he was showing signs that he was understanding.
It was a true miracle.
I did foster Teldrick for six years.
And then finally, in March of 2021,
he was legally adopted,
and finally, Teldrick Albrecq;
which he's been wanting a long time.
Everyone always says, "Oh my gosh, you saved Teldrick."
But, in reality, he probably did save me too.
It was someone to give my like purpose and guidance,
just to kind of just put you in the right direction.
Something was lacking, like a bigger picture,
a bigger meaning was lacking from my life,
I think, at that time.
It was definitely Teldrick.
So, just put me on the right path
and gave me purpose, meaning,
and sense of being a parent, it was awesome.
(audience cheering)
Oh, Isaiah, you're outside Kim and Teldrick's house
right now, along with the crew from the CBS2 Los Angeles,
and they have no idea that they're about to be on this show,
and we have a massive surprise for them.
Isaiah, I love you, let's do this.
All right, let's do this.
(door knocking)
Hi, Kim and Teldrick.
Hello. Hi!
How are you guys?
We're really good.
How are you?
Good, good.
My name is Isaiah from "The Drew Barrymore show."
How you guys doing, good?
We're a wonderful, Isaiah.
Come outside, I got something for you guys.
(Ross chuckles)
Hello?
Hi!
Smile, you're on "The Drew Barrymore Show" guys.
Hi Kim, how are you?
(audience cheering)
Say hi to Drew and Ross.
Hi, Drew, hi, Ross.
Hi, guys!
Kim-
Say hi.
Hi.
Sorry, you say that you knew that
you always had a special connection to Teldrick
when he was your student.
And I was just curious if you could tell us about that.
There was just this really positive aura with Teldrick,
from the day I met him.
The smile on his face, the light in his eyes.
So full of joy and happiness.
And he just brought that everyone around him,
he brought that to everyone around him.
There's just something about him.
And I'm wondering what that moment was like
when the adoption was official,
when he became your son and you became a family.
Honestly, that was the best moment of my life.
It was a whirlwind of emotions,
relief, happiness, joy.
Yeah. We find each other
when we need each other.
That's absolutely amazing.
Kim, tell me how do you want this story to inspire others?
Well, I hope that this story inspires others
that people will believe in miracles.
Teldrick truly is my miracle.
I never in a million years thought that
he would be my son.
And we're here doing all this now.
But miracles are out there, they happen.
And also, I hope it inspires people to adopt.
These children are everywhere.
And if it's even in your mind at all, go for it and do it.
Because the bond that you'll build
with this child is unconditional.
Oh, Kim.
(audience cheering)
That's so wonderful.
Kim, another thing I heard you do to expand your horizons,
is that you guys love to travel together.
We do love to travel together. (chuckles)
But you had to stop in the pandemic, right?
You had to cut a trip off even, that you had planned.
We sure did. We were in December,
we were gonna go to Bali for three weeks,
and obviously, with the pandemic that was not possible.
So, we are waiting for that to come back to us.
Well, we have a little surprise for you.
We're sending you on a
six nights, seven day Royal Suite Stay,
to the Stunning Boutique Resort, The Mansion Bali.
(audience cheering)
How about that?
Surprise!
Oh, my God.
Going to Bali.
Way to go buddy. That cool?
Yes.
Thank you so much, Drew. Thank you.
Oh, I'm so excited for both of you.
Thank you so much, Drew.
Absolutely. Thank you.
(audience cheering)
I love you, Drew. I love you Ross.
I love you Iasiah, so much.
We love you!
Also I wanna give our friends at CBS2 Los Angeles,
a big special shout out,
and thank you for helping us pull this off.
So thank you to our affiliate station.
We love you. We'll be right back.
Thank you!
(upbeat music)